en este vídeo vamos a hablar de la
conservación del momento angular lo cual
es muy útil porque nos permite explicar
diversos fenómenos en el universo desde
el porque la velocidad angular de los
patinadores se incrementa cuando acercan
los brazos y piernas a su cuerpo hasta
el porque un objeto que gira alrededor
de una estrella y se va acercando cada
vez más con un movimiento en espiral
pareciera que su movimiento angular y
rapidez angular aumenta y comienza a
rotar cada vez más rápido esto lo vemos
mucho en simulaciones de fenómenos de
objetos astronómicos
la idea general aquí es que tenemos un
momento angular inicial para un sistema
y mientras a este sistema no se le
aplique una tuerca externa el momento
angular final será igual que el momento
angular inicial una forma de pensar en
esto es imaginar que tenemos algo que
está girando alrededor de un punto por
ejemplo puede ser un disco que está
girando sobre una mesa y lo estamos
observando desde arriba un punto en este
disco está girando en esta dirección con
una velocidad de magnitud v ahora
imaginemos que hay un objeto de arcilla
o plastilina que se está moviendo en
esta dirección de colisión con este
objeto de acá
este objeto se está moviendo con una
velocidad de magnitud 5 v si vemos a
este disco y este objeto como un sistema
y recordemos que siempre debemos indicar
que es lo que comprende el sistema que
estamos analizando si vemos a este disco
y este objeto como en un sistema cómo va
a cambiar el momento angular antes de
que colisión en estos dos objetos y
después de que colisionan vamos a
dibujar el escenario después de la
colisión ahora el objeto de arcilla está
apelmazado con este disco y van a rotar
juntos aún no sabemos cuál es la masa de
este disco o la masa de este objeto por
lo que aún no sabemos en qué dirección
estarán rotando juntos después de la
colisión pero la pregunta es cómo
cambiará el momento angular de este
estado inicial a este estado final pausa
en el vídeo y piensen al respecto quizá
ya se dieron cuenta de que aplica lo que
mencionamos al principio como estamos
considerando todo esto como un solo
sistema y no estamos aplicando una torta
externa al sistema el momento angular se
va a mantener exactamente igual aquí
debemos tener siempre presente que es lo
que forma parte de nuestro sistema
si por ejemplo dijéramos que el sistema
es este disco solamente sin incluir al
objeto de arcilla que está en curso de
colisión con el disco entonces el
momento angular del disco si va a
cambiar pero por qué acaso esto va en
contra de la ley de la conservación del
momento no ya que este objeto de arcilla
no forma parte del sistema y cuando
golpea al disco va a proporcionar una
torta externa al sistema pues nuestro
sistema incluye solamente al disco pero
regresando al ejemplo inicial donde el
sistema incluye al disco y al objeto y
no hay una torta externa que afecte al
sistema combinado el momento angular del
sistema no va a cambiar ahora que
sabemos que el momento angular de un
sistema es constante siempre y cuando no
se aplique una tuerca neta externa a él
analicemos la situación en la que la
velocidad angular de los patinadores
aumenta cuando acercan sus piernas y
brazos a su cuerpo ustedes pueden
simular esto aunque no tan elegantemente
si usan una silla de oficina giratoria
como la que estoy dibujando aquí si
ustedes giran sentados en la silla con
las piernas estiradas al principio van a
girar lentamente pero
se acercan las piernas a la silla
comenzarán a girar más rápido porque
tendrán una mayor rapidez angular por
qué ocurre esto para responder a esta
pregunta veamos la fórmula del momento
angular que denominamos con la letra l
mayúscula hay varias maneras en las que
podemos expresar esta fórmula podemos
escribir la como el momento de inercia y
por la rapidez angular o mega quizá la
fórmula les parezca algo extraña pero
tiene una fórmula análoga bastante común
en el mundo lineal el momento lineal es
igual a la masa por la velocidad la
razón por la cual estas fórmulas son
análogas es porque la masa nos indica la
inercia de un objeto cuánta fuerza se
necesita aplicar para acelerar este
objeto
efe igual a m por a con el momento de
inercia tenemos algo similar pero en
lugar de pensar cómo acelerar algo
linealmente esto nos dice que tan
difícil es darle una aceleración angular
o cuánta torca hay que aplicar en lugar
de cuánta fuerza lineal hay que aplicar
y en lugar de la velocidad tenemos la
rapidez angular que a veces también se
le llama velocidad angular pero quizá al
ver esta fórmula ustedes
que no les ayuda en nada a explicar el
aumento de velocidad cuando giran en una
silla de oficina con las piernas pegadas
o el por qué esta patinadora incrementa
la rapidez de su giro al pegar sus
brazos a su cuerpo para lograr esto
debemos pensar en que el momento de
inercia puede expresarse como m por
radio al cuadrado y aquí seguimos
teniendo a omega esta es otra manera de
expresar el momento angular cuando la
patinadora pega sus brazos al cuerpo no
cambia su masa eso permanece constante
el radio es un poco complicado de
imaginar cuando tenemos un cuerpo humano
pero veámoslo así si tenemos un punto de
masa rotando de esta forma entonces este
es el radio pero cuando tenemos una
estructura más compleja como el cuerpo
humano podemos imaginar el radio como la
distancia promedio de la masa al centro
de rotación por lo que cuando la
patinadora acerca a sus brazos al cuerpo
esa distancia promedio disminuye este
valor disminuye pero si eso disminuye y
el momento angular permanece constante
porque no tenemos una torta neta
aplicada al sistema entonces este valor
tiene que aumentar para
constante al momento angular eso es
exactamente lo que ocurre aquí
la rapidez angular aumenta conforme
disminuye el radio eso también explica
el porqué si tenemos un tipo de planeta
y hay un satélite en órbita alrededor de
él mientras este satélite se acerca más
al planeta
su rapidez angular va a aumentar cada
vez más esto ocurre porque cuando
tenemos un radio más grande la rapidez
angular es menor pero al acercarse al
objeto el radio disminuye por lo que la
rapidez angular tiene que aumentar para
mantener constante el momento angular
con esto terminamos y espero que se
diviertan mucho girando en sillas de
oficina